grab a glass of milk and a hot Queen
made Pride lasagna it's time to sit down
and enjoy the first boy's spin-off
that'll have you never looking at the
word Jumanji the same in this
turbo-sized video we'll be taking a look
at the first three episodes their
connection to the boys and tons of
little Easter eggs that are easy to miss
and you'll want to stick around till the
end of the video where I go over the
season trailers looking for Clues on
what might happen next now make sure to
enroll and hit that like button this
season is gonna be wild I'm super
focused
I'm super inclusive I'm super abled it's
that time of year again where soups are
drafted to cities and traded around like
professional athletes this is eight
years ago prior to the events of the
boys a train is the number one ranked
student at gedulkin University where a
familiar face Madeleine Stilwell who had
her face melted by homelander at the end
of season one welcomes him to the seven
eight trans success wouldn't be possible
without the help of Professor Richard
Brink Brinkerhoff the chair of the crime
fighting department at cadolkan U this
guy has trained some of the world's
best-known soups including Queen Maeve
the deep and future member of the seven
Golden Boy played by Arnold
Schwarzenegger's son will get into him
in a bit the dulcan University was
founded by Vaught International in 1965
and named after Patrick adulkin an
homage to John goodokin from the comics
who's basically a child molesting
Charles Xavier if you go to
godolcanuniversity.com you can actually
take a tour of the campus Guided by
Maverick your invisible ra who we meet
briefly in the show I love translucent
statue being non-existent because he's
invisible and according to a Twitter
post a Year's tuition is seventy
thousand dollars so I won't be attending
anytime soon it's eight years ago we
meet young Marie Moreau who's trying to
recreate Kendall Jenner's iconic
Instagram pose with her sister Annabeth
unbeknownst to her her parents gave her
compound v as a child but it seemed to
have no effect on her at least not until
now puberty has triggered her ability to
control blood and she accidentally kills
both her mother and father leaving her
little sister to think she's a monster
the fate of Annabeth is a bit of a
mystery Marie's drive to become the best
soup there is and eventually join the
seven is tied to her need to prove to
her sister that she's not a monster all
we know about Annabeth was that she was
put into foster care and Marie hasn't
heard from her since if we're to Believe
TV host Haley Miller Annabeth said she
wanted nothing to do with Marie but I
think there's a lot lot more here it's
entirely possible that if Murray's
parents gave Marie compound V they would
have also given it to Annabeth so Marie
could have a sister out there with
superpowers it could even be someone we
already know in the boy's Universe the
extent of Marie's Powers aren't quite
known either not only can she control
her own blood but those of others seen
when she manipulates the blood of the
woman almost killed by Andre I'm also
guessing that she has pretty good
regenerative power since every time she
wants to use her powers she has to cut
her Palms I'm interested as the series
goes on to see how this power can be
used in cool and unexpected ways now
Marie has spent the last eight years in
this avat-run Foster School aptly named
the Red River Institute here we can see
Marie's obsession with soups with
posters for Queen Maeve and Golden Boy
on her wall she even has a godolcan you
calendar with a date she's set to hear
whether or not she got in this place
even has trauma circles where one guy
talks about when Starlight came forward
it gave him the strength to speak his
truth reference to Starlight
highlighting the abuses she faced while
being a member of the seven particularly
the Deep sexual assault Marie sees a
young girl being taken to the Elmira
adult rehab center a place will learn
the students at Red River go when they
don't get adopted and according to
Marie's teacher this is not a place you
want to go it's run by vaught's global
Wellness division which runs all sorts
of medical and rehab facilities across
the country it's where a train and
Termite went to deal with their
addictions and a commercial for it was
released back in 2021 on vot news where
do you turn to fill that void heroin
enemas you better believe their soup
porn with such fascinating titles as
deep deser in the blowhole and mave
cheats on her cuck boyfriend with
homebanger those of you with a Keen Eye
will remember homebanger from season 2
as one of lamplighter's favorite actors
the Gen V YouTube pages also come out
with a safe sex PSA and from there we
learn of superporn.com which is an
actual website you can purchase your
favorite toys I can't even show you half
the things on there Marie finds out
she's been accepted and she doesn't want
to screw up this opportunity because it
could be a way for her to erase the past
and make a name for herself we get this
awesome orientation video where Dean and
Dira Shetty welcomes new students no
word yet if she's named after executive
producer of the show pavanchetti
godulkin is everything you'd expect from
a university in the Vaught Universe not
only can you take important classes such
as hero ethics but also understanding
branding because a soup is really only
as good as his brand although there are
probably more Avenues one can pursue at
God you the two main ones focused on in
the first three episodes are crime
fighting at The Lamplighter School of
crime fighting and Performing Arts whose
building is named after our favorite
chimp loving soup Crimson countess
Don't Cry of great importance is the
School's ranking system which social
media director Jeff says is determined
by a mix of talent skill brand awareness
and social mentions these rankings are
determined by the school's trustees so
plenty of room for them to be
manipulated currently Luke Reardon AKA
Golden Boy is the school's number one
ranked student it is set to join the
seven remember after the events of
season three of the boys Starlight and
queen Maeve are out leaving room open
for new members speaking of which it
looks like the epic battle that took
place between Soldier Boy and the boys
at Vaught tower has been covered up to
look like a Russian plot the events of
gen V take place after season three of
the boys and before season four so we
get these fun little tidbits like
homelander's lawyer saying he quotes
stood his ground this of course a
reference to homelander murdering
someone in Cold Blood at the end of the
season so it looks like it's landed him
in a lot of legal trouble honestly I
just hope they don't discontinue the
brave me vegetarian Pride lasagna Marie
arrives at the godolphin dorms and I
can't help but think it's secretly a
prison students have to walk through
these metal detecting sort of machines
and the windows can't open nor can be
broken here we meet Emma AKA Little
Cricket a soup who has the ability to
get extremely small although to do so
she has to purge like Marie we haven't
been shown the real extent of her powers
just yet like just how small can she get
before she dies and if she can get small
can she also get big we know when she
eats she gets larger but can she get
infinitely larger or does she Plateau at
a point Emma has a dwindling YouTube fan
base and it's clear when mean girl
Justine betrays her by telling everyone
her secret that she purges to get small
that she cares a lot about what other
people think of her when offered a
reality show that will delve into the
Dark World of Eating Disorders she
rejects it that's not the person she
wants to be so expect her character Arc
this season to revolve around her
discovering who she really is our first
real look at Golden Boy season flaming
up and ripping the arms off the
incredible Steve who thank God
incredibly has the ability to reattach
his arms golden boy gets so hot that his
clothes melt off leaving his ding dong
exposed for all to see it's like a big
fire AC cucumber later Brink will show
Golden Boy a mock-up of a special suit
worth millions that won't burn under his
intense heat a suit for when he joins
the seven hell he can even have Maeve or
starlight's old apartment this should be
amazing news for Golden Boy something
he's worked at his entire life but just
take a look at his face something isn't
right and this something may have to do
with his brother Sam he hears his
brother's voice calling to him as if he
were in a dream we'll later learn that
Sam was killed a few years ago or so we
think Golden Boy tells his girlfriend
Kate that he's been having nightmares
again nightmares that include trees this
is a reference to the wallpaper found in
the secret underground facility
underneath good dolkin a facility where
golden Boy's brother has been held for
the past few years and paint full
experiments tested on him meanwhile
Marie gets her schedule and finds out
she hasn't been accepted into Brink's
first year intro to crime fighting a
mandatory class for anyone majoring in
that field this is where she meets
Jordan brings head ta who has the
ability to morph into male and female
versions of herself or himself or they
self I actually don't know what Pro
dance to use the reasoning for her
rejection is pretty simple there are
other kids who have solved murders or
have millions of followers what does
Marie have nothing and it wouldn't be a
normal day at gdulkin until your teacher
comes out and shoots you Jordan
apparently has steel skin and we learned
that Ashley Barrett now CEO of Vaught
has asked Brink to speak at a retreat in
Sun Valley we'll see Ashley throughout
the first three episodes mainly to keep
tabs on the dean and her handling of the
woods a place if discovered could mean
ruin and potentially their own deaths
now Marie pleads to bring to letter in
the class but he's not budging only five
kids a year score a city contract and
the rest sing and dance for VOD he tells
her to just enjoy being in Performing
Arts memory is understandably upset this
is something she's wanted for the past
eight years and now it's being dashed
because of one man's decision as she
walks back to her dorm that night we get
a glimpse of evangelized soldier boy
statue a man who was deemed a terrorist
by Vaught in season three of the boys
here Marie gets to show off how how she
can use her blood as a lasso in stopping
a crazed meth out tweaker or so we think
working alongside Andre who has
telekinetic Powers the two are able to
stop him but this sets forth a chain of
events that will forever change their
lives this chance encounter get his name
is Chance has Andre invite Marie for a
night on the town with golden boy and
his friends something that would see her
going past curfew remember she doesn't
want to screw up this opportunity but
then again how often do you get to hang
out with golden boy in the popular kids
at the top of vot tower Marie has her
first real interaction with golden boy
he opens up about his brother passing
and Chi about proving to her sister that
she's not a monster but it's golden boy
who leaves her with this profound
statement being a hero is uh it's not
what you think you know if you're gonna
do this make sure you do it for you I
think this is really important for Marie
as she seems to enjoy getting swept up
in the celebrity as the episodes go on
will she let power and fame get in the
way of why she wanted to become a super
hero in the first place meanwhile a
lonely Emma is called over Liam who has
her gets small and hang off his dick and
of course my parents walked in on me as
soon as this scene was playing I also
like the recommended videos on her
YouTube page with titles such as I ate
Whataburger for 30 days straight or how
to make 20K a week with votcoin with
Golden Boy leaving good dolkin soon it
means there will be a post open for the
number one ranking Jordan says she'll
never be number one because a
sex-changing soup doesn't look good for
certain parts of America and Andre
doesn't want to be number one because it
means he'll have to work with his dad
Andre's Dad used polarity a former
member of the seven who wants nothing
more than his son to follow in his
footsteps polarity also happens to be on
the Board of Trustees the tension
between him and his son is high it seems
polarity cares more about the fame
associated with becoming a soup than
actually saving people that should be
you up there Andre and Marie's a night
on the town goes awry when Andre tries
to impress a girl by floating a coin
he's shaped into a bird into another
Dude's drink but when he suddenly pushed
the coin pierces a woman's neck almost
killing her thank God Marie is there who
can control the woman's blood loss until
paramedics arrive this is all recorded
on video making Marie a hero in my award
for favorite background actor goes to
this guy he's do a great brigger back
the next day Marie is called into
Brink's office where she believes she'll
be congratulated for saving a woman's
life and thus accepted into the crime
fighting class but this couldn't be
further from the truth her getting
caught on camera jeopardized Andre
Jordan and Golden Boy Who were with her
that night all hopped up on drugs if one
of them had been caught their careers
would be over and just think of the
thousands of lives that would go unsaved
should these Brave Heroes be hashtag
canceled so Marie is expelled a
sacrifice Brink must make to protect his
favorite students being a hero a real
hero it's about sacrifice but who told
Brink that all of them were out past
curfew in episode 3 it's implied that
Andre told his father what happened that
night and his father was the one who
went to bring remember polarity will go
to any lengths to protect his son and
his future bonus points if you saw the
campus Vada Burger in the background
Whataburger
put our meat Burger in your mouth hole
in Golden boy's dorm he has another one
of his nightmares but this time his
little brother Sam says it's not a dream
we'll later meet Sam and I'm wondering
if his powers allow him to communicate
via these dreams Sam needs his help now
we don't know what really happens
between now and when Golden Boy Burns
Brink to death the only real clue comes
in episode 2 when Andre finds golden
boy's message Golden Boy has somehow
found out that Brink was conducting
experiments not only on his brother who
is still alive but Golden Boy himself
just how exactly Golden Boy has no
recollection of this remains to be seen
Sam must have told Golden Boy all of
this and perhaps even shown him via
these quote-unquote dreams leading
Golden Boy to kill Brink an event which
Marie Witnesses first hand and of course
we can't have any Witnesses so our
Golden Boy turns not so golden in Hunts
Marie down but it's actually Jordan who
goes toe-to-toe with him in an epic
battle that eventually makes its way
outside where Andre is promoting a
train's Turbo rush I wouldn't pour this
on my dick if he cured cancer Andre is
the only one who can calm Golden Boy
down but before Golden Boy
self-destructs himself he says something
to Andre we only hear about in episode
2. your dad has it a reference to Golden
boy putting his phone in polarity's
Statue it takes no time at all for
Vaught to twist golden boy's murder of
brink as a chronic drug user
experiencing a full psychotic break the
only thing Ashley seems concerned about
is the 45 million dollars worth of
Golden Boy merch which is now pretty
much useless Dean Shetty ensures Ashley
that everything at good dolkin is under
control after all she was the one who
mitigated the disaster that was the
compound V Scandal it's Murray and Andre
Who come out on top being seen as Heroes
who took on the murderous Golden Boy
Jordan however due to her sexuality was
brushed aside even though she was the
one responsible for stopping Golden Boy
when things could have gone much worse
thus the trustees have shifted the
rankings putting Andre as number one
demoting Jordan to number five and read
to number eight hashtag black girl magic
Jeff the godolcan media director even
hooks Marie up with a phone since a soup
of her caliber will want to start
building followers a makeshift memorial
for Professor Brink has popped up on
campus where Kate finds a student named
Rufus making fun of her he's got the
trumpian keep America safe hat and his
friend has a homelander sorry snowflake
shirt which we saw many of his followers
wear during his rallies meanwhile Andre
asks his dad if Golden Boy said anything
to him before he went crazy after all
one of golden boy's final cryptic
messages to Andre was your dad has it
polarity has no idea what he's talking
about so Andre enlists the help of Marie
to get to the bottom of what happened
but Marie has learned her lesson she has
to stay out of trouble remember it was
her going out with them that got her in
this mess in the first place and she
doesn't want to mess it up in acting
class it's our favorite Donna the seven
director Adam bork who's in director
Purgatory for exposing himself to Minka
Kelly Emma thinks she's gonna partner up
with her dick hanging buddy only to find
out he's moved on to a new girl and if
that embarrassment wasn't enough Emma
will team up with Justine who ends up
using her for juicy gossip on her
YouTube channel I don't blame you
Justine I do it too for those sweet
sweet subscribers because of Marie's
heroic exploits defending adulkin from
Golden Boy and her surge in popularity
Marie is allowed to audit the junior
year classes she'll even have one-on-one
meetings with the dean that sort of act
like therapy sessions however I'm sure
the dean has ulterior motives I wonder
if she knows a little more about Marie's
past and her sister than she's letting
on Jordan also takes a moment to dig
into Marie piss that she took credit for
her fighting Golden Boy but let's be
real Jordan is no saint she was the one
who rejected Marie from Brink's crime
finding class and was totally fine with
her being expelled but even though she
did that she asked Marie to do the right
thing and tell the truth tonight when
she has her live interview tell the
world it was Jordan who fought off
Golden Boy on the television we get two
brief glimpses of the news that show a
Robert Singer Campaign Act a character
we saw in cahoots with Vaught and his
running mate the notorious head popper
Victoria Newman no doubt if they win I
think it won't be long before President
singer is killed and the secret soup
Victoria takes over as President we also
learned that homelander is on trial what
we don't know yet is whether or not this
trial will be resolved before the boy
season 4 or if it will be a plot point
of the Season Emma divulges that her
real hero is Queen Maeve she wants to be
in inspiration to other kids out there
not this attention-seeking Fame [__]
perhaps this is why she is so insistent
on agreeing to Andre's plans to
infiltrate the woods she wants to prove
that she has what it takes to be a real
hero I also love that we get to see a
glimpse of vot plus a vaught's own
streaming service which has all the
termite titles you could ask for Dean
Shetty has access to the woods in fact
she seems to be the one in charge as
further experiments are conducted on Sam
we can see from the security camera
footage that there are several other
inmates here later when Andre accesses
Brink's computer we'll see the names of
13 individuals currently in prison there
I like how Sam's room has posters of
payback and this means Noir two films
created by famous producer The Legend
who he met in season three Andre enlists
the help of Kate to get to the bottom of
what happened to Golden Boy so they
start in his dorm room where everything
has been cleared out even his dildos not
to mention the room smells like bleach
it seems someone may be trying to cover
their tracks I love this Crimson
Countess poster which translates from
Latin to remember to be bold hidden in
his father's dick is golden boy's phone
in which Golden Boy has left a message
for Andre his brother is still alive in
a place called The Woods underneath the
school and Brink was a part of it Sam
was alleged to have killed himself at
Sage Grove the psych hospital we saw the
boys infiltrate in season two in fact
we'll see a flashback to that hospital
and a brief Cameo from love sausage
Marie reads her script in preparation
for her live interview it just goes to
show you how manipulative and
overreaching VOD is everything down to
these interviews are completely scripted
so they can control the narrative but
the real dilemma here is if Marie will
go off script and tell the truth that it
was Jordan who really saved the day this
is a major character moment for her she
can do the right thing and tell the
truth but she doesn't Marie is enjoying
this newfound Fame and it could lead to
her finding her sister even though the
interviewer told her they tried to
contact her and apparently she wanted
nothing to do with her as Dean Shetty
says that could be total BS I also love
how they dressed Marie up in blood red
and she has these swirling red
backgrounds during her photo shoot they
are going to Market and brand the hell
out of this girl and polarity is super
pissed about this Marie is stealing the
spotlight from his son who has gone
M.I.A that's because he's breaking into
Brink's office a group of intruders grab
the dean's laptop but not before Andre
gets proof that Sam is still alive he
follows the group downstairs and
Witnesses the murder of a janitor now
these Intruders have a special device
that incapacitates Andre because soups
have a wider range of hearing it's
programmed to affect only them but Kate
comes to save the day who you uses her
power of persuasion which she calls
pushing to have the guards perform
fellatio on a flashlight but Kate's
power comes at a price she can only use
it so much before convulsing when she
awakes Andre is there taking care of her
and in a few moments he'll take care of
her another way by engaging in some soup
sex with his best friend's ex if you're
ever in doubt the most heroic decision
is to abstain from super powered sexual
activity altogether nerd three years ago
we get a flashback at Sage Grove like
Golden Boy Sam was given compound V but
he also happens to be schizophrenic
whether this was a result of the
compound V is yet to be known as well as
the extent of Sam's powers we know he
has super strength and the ability to
contact others through dreamlike Visions
I'm really curious to see why he was
taken to the woods and why they're
conducting these experiments on him
Marie warms up to Dean Shetty who
invites her as a guest to tonight's
Memorial Gala in silent auction a silent
auction that has such prizes as Vitality
products a night with the deep and
signed a train trainers we even learned
that the dean had a daughter past tense
but we're not sure if this means she was
killed or is simply no longer in her
life I love how there's already a
missing janitor's poster the gala really
reinforces how her students are
pressured by their parents into being
who they really don't want to be
polarity pushes Andre Tiffany wants Emma
to have her own reality show and
Jordan's father wants him to embrace
being a boy you can be a boy forever if
you want without realizing his sex isn't
what defines him I've never changed Dad
I've always
just been me I will say it's gonna be
wild to be able to experience sex both
as a man and woman with Emma all on
board to help Andre rescue golden Boy's
brother she shrinks down to small size
and gains access to his cell but Sam is
a schizophrenic and upon seeing her
questions if she's real are you real and
if that isn't bad enough one of his
favorite films is Waterworld one of the
biggest box office flops ever the
movie's message however resonates with
him and probably would with Emma too
it's a story about being alone and
finding one's own humanity and these two
definitely feel alone back up top
however Andre makes the mistake of
telling his dad about the woods Mr
Anderson knows all about it and warns
his son not to say another word looking
into it could get himself killed in an
effort to appease Sam Emma tells him
that she was sent there by his brother
but doesn't disclose that his brother is
dead something that will undoubtedly
come in biter in the ass later on
especially if these two end up being a
thing was it just me or were they vibing
up top Marie finally divulges that she
was responsible for killing her family
but to her surprise she isn't the only
one with a sob story Kate didn't realize
that her powers had manifested and while
on a camping trip told her brother to go
away and never come back and that's
exactly what he did his body was never
found from that moment on her parents
never touched her again Marie also
realizes that Dean Shetty is being
pretty shitty and only using her to make
a buck AKA fundraise so it seems her
newfound friendship with her isn't as
genuine as first thought amid a stack of
Queen Maeve and payback Comics Emma
watches as Sam is electrocuted and his
cell is rated the first electrocution
comes from the electrical floor however
the second seems to be operated by this
device that can electrocute Sam himself
unless of course this guard is wearing
some sort of anti-electrical boots
perhaps they've implanted Sam with their
own version of a shock collar in an
effort to control him Emma leaps to the
rescue and climbs into the guard's ear
simulating what happens to me every time
I hear Nickelback it's not long before
morgar's pour in and it seems as though
the two of them will be caught will she
and Sam be saved by Andre and the crew
the last time we saw Andre he rounded up
Marie Kate and Jordan telling them that
Emma's in trouble so maybe they're able
to break them all out but to get a
better idea of what we can expect this
season we now delve into our trailer
sleuthing section keep in mind I won't
be going over every shot just the ones
that pertain to information we got in
the first three episodes it looks as
though we have more people escaping the
woods seen here by this woman with laser
eyes wearing the same standard gray
sweater and sweatpants as the inmates
and it also looks as though we'll see
other inmates Andre shows us that their
dorm rooms are actually prisons as he
telekinetically lowers these metal bars
over the windows in a later shot we'll
see students struggle to get out of the
dorms before these giant middle doors
close on them here's Victoria Newman
telling someone quote this is your shot
at real power we'll see her at some sort
of campaign event with both supporters
and detractors it looks as though it's
an event put on by vot news with Cameron
Coleman acting as interviewer things
seem to get out of control here when one
of the attendees uses her screen power
no doubt on some sort of anti-sup bigot
here's Dean Shetty overlooking a bunch
of dead guards could Sam have gone
psycho mode and kill all of them taking
Emma with him or maybe Emma makes her
way out through this drain pipe notice
her little shoe here we know that they
do make it out because here they are
making out in front of a polarity crane
game looks like Dean Shetty finds the
shoe meaning she'll be able to determine
Emma was involved I love this Andre uses
his powers to telekinetically throw a
keg at Rufus that homelander supporter
who hates Kate later Marie tells Jordan
that she exploded someone's dick and
judging by the shot just before that
it's of a bloody Rufus so maybe he has
that to look forward to here we have Sam
looking like a student at the dorms I
have no idea how they'd get him to be a
student unless he was supposed to be
hiding here after the escape and is this
just me or is this a Marie and Jordan
kiss here we have Marie using her powers
on Sam it looks as though Sam has
Tracked Down The Doctor Who did
experiments on him and is wanting some
good old-fashioned payback something
Jordan Andre and Marie won't let him get
away with now I don't think we've seen
this shot of Golden Boy are we seeing
another flashback or perhaps a clone of
him a result of the experiments done to
him now I'm super excited about this
show and hope you'll stick with me as I
break down the entire season thanks for
watching please make sure to like And
subscribe and for more bad takes you can
follow me on Twitter and Instagram at
Big story T until next time remember
[Music]
foreign